[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
stature de grand prix sont un peu comme
les hirondelles reviennent chaque année
sur les circuits avec le beau temps ici
maurice trintignant sur sa lotus numéro
12 après le départ du 22e grand prix de
pau
depuis 25 ans le pilote en scène il a 44
ans participe à presque toutes les
grandes épreuves
circuit le poly porte bonheur
ordinairement
doit avoir le jeu doha il a encore bon
pied bon oeil il conduit sa vieille
lotus avec sagesse et virtuosité
ce qui n'est pas le cas de tous les
concurrents on dérape ou bien longtemps
c'est mécanique comme l'ancien champion
du monde jack brabham et lantourne après
204 de moyenne sur un circuit très
accidenté ainsi y en a aucune difficulté
à repousser toutes les attaques même
celle de la ferrari numéro 6 de ricardo
rodriguez l'enfant terrible de la course
automobile il sera sans doute la grande
vedette de 2
[Musique]
dans un palais bourbon dans la façade
disparaît derrière un tamis
l'échafaudage l'assemblée pour écouter
la déclaration du nouveau premier
ministre s'est réuni au grand complet
[Musique]
le
devant l'assemblée présidée par monsieur
chaban delmas monsieur georges pompidou
a exposé le programme de son
gouvernement qui fait une large place au
problème social il faut relever aussi
l'appel au bon sens lancé aux européens
d'algérie et le pas en avant fait aussi
bien sur le plan de l'alliance
atlantique que sur celui de l'europe
unie
[Musique]
par ailleurs en ces mêmes journées
monsieur ap rahman farès président de
l'exécutif provisoire d'algérie s'est
rendu à paris où il a été reçu par le
général de gaulle à sa sortie de
l'elysée monsieur farès assailli par les
journalistes a déclaré que la date du
vote de l'autodétermination et est
d'ores et déjà fixée
[Musique]
à oran qui s'opposent encore en
multipliant des incidents meurtriers à
l'application des accords d'evian de
nombreux renforts ont investi la ville
le commandement militaire a maintenant
sa disposition des forces suffisantes
pour rétablir l'ordre
le bouclage de certains secteurs
névralgiques et des fouilles méthodiques
ont permis de retrouver des documents
importants et des armes
[Musique]
est-ce pour bientôt le retour de la
légalité à oran
autrefois les hôpitaux n'étaient que des
centres d'hébergement relevant du
domaine de la charité est destiné à
recueillir les indigents certains
bâtiments devenus vétustes et
quelquefois sordide craie pour les
malades un abattement de psy chic qui
peut être une véritable hantise pour les
hospitalisés
avec la semaine nationale des hôpitaux
la fédération hospitalière de france
nous permet d'apprécier les efforts
accomplis le malade de la plus être
seulement un cas pour les statistiques
un client pour les hôpitaux mais un
autre
en rompant avec la politique d'austérité
et la carence du financement qui ont
freiné l'évolution hospitalière
l'hôpital sera est déjà ce qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être un
grand service public au service de votre
santé
[Musique]
notre époque qui est celle de la
technique suscite et rend nécessaire
l'expansion économique sur le territoire
français des fabrications de toute
nature se développe depuis l'industrie
lourde jusqu aux industries alimentaire
c'est ainsi que certaines brasseries
compte aujourd'hui comme des modèles du
genre quant à l'automaticité et son
corollaire la productivité mais de
telles entreprises représentent des
investissements considérables le crédit
national a été créée justement pour
assurer par des prêts une part du
financement et permettre à l'économie
d'aller délibérément de l'avant
son action touche tous les secteurs
industriels et commerciaux dans le
domaine encore neuf des produits
chimiques elle a permis la réalisation
de la première fabrique de caoutchouc
synthétique en france
[Musique]
l'économie se doit de regarder vers
l'avenir de le préparer
c'est pourquoi il importe d'investir dès
à présent d'investir largement
roubaix a grandi mais n'a pas changé
mais dans la ville cette jeune main qui
chaque matin arrêté son réveil est
maintenant une vieille 9 jeanne coque
ouvrière à la redoute à roubaix vient
d'être après 68 ans de service dans la
même maison décorée de la légion
d'honneur
et il est bien qu'une distinction de
cette valeur viennent récompenser tant
d'années au travail depuis le temps au
jeune fille madame jeanne coque figurer
dans le groupe d'une photo aujourd'hui
jauni
[Musique]
aujourd'hui encore chaque matin une
jeune ouvrière vient prendre à sa porte
la vieille ouvrière
ensemble les deux compagnes les deux
époques font le trajet qui les sépare de
la fabrique et le philosophe pourra
trouver dans cette route commune de deux
êtres que c'est par tant d'années de
subtiles et sensible correspondance la
même maison rajeuni bien sûr les mêmes
gestes à l'arrivée
les mêmes gestes au travail dans des
locaux qui depuis 68 ans on s'en doute
bien changer la vie
la légion d'honneur pour une vie de
travail et d'exactitude voilà une légion
d'honneur bien placé
[Musique]
l'ancien régime le nouveau régime et la
formule est valable pour les boissons
comme pour les rythmes
m
et voici pour cela leurs des souvenirs
parce que nous avons tous dans ses
quelque chose et l'on peut dire l'âge de
chacun si l'on connaît la danse de son
temps
on en connaît encore qu'il vire à la fin
de la belle époque l'apparition du tango
moustache conquérante et bottines à
boutons
et et certaines bouches de métro garde
encore le souvenir de ce fameux bon
temps que rompit la guerre de 14
l'exposition des arts décoratifs avec un
doumergue souriant et des messieurs en
haut-de-forme coïncida avec le temps du
charleston
[Musique]
on vit bâtir la ligne siegfried et la
ligne maginot aux accents du landais
walk qui parti d'un quartier de londres
n'évite à rien
[Musique]
paris connu l'occupation
et c'est dans ce climat que naquit le
soigne
[Musique]
l'occupation se termina le temps du
swing aussi mais il y eu de bruyantes
séquelles le rock
le cha cha cha succéda au rock en
l'accusant de mièvrerie dans une époque
aux crises forcené
[Musique]
puis le twist vingt sept danses
exceptionnelle qui exige un minimum de
place pour un maximum de sensations
[Musique]
mais le twist et il en perte de vitesse
on parle d'une renaissance du tango on a
vu renton il dansait
[Musique]
oh
le tango avec guy béart commence à
compter ses champions
allons-nous rajeunir de 60 ans
[Musique]